okay there is a new world record largest
prime number ever just announced
yesterday and today I had a special
delivery this arrived in the post in
here we have the newly discovered
Mersenne Prime in here is 2 ^ 74 million
two hundred and seven thousand two
hundred and eighty one make sure I get
that right and if you actually work -
one trivial at that size if you were
actually to print this number out its 22
million it's over 22 million digits it's
around 22 million three hundred and
thirty-eight thousand six hundred and
eighteen digits and no one will be
foolish enough to get that printed and
shipped to them the moment the number
was announced other than us so let's get
in there there it is there it is this is
the new world record look at that that
is 2 ^ 74 million two hundred and seven
thousand twenty one minus one these are
the digits volume 2 volume 2 of 3 so
there is there's volume 3 and so there's
another third and finally here I guess
we should start at the beginning this is
there you are volume or you want look at
that this is the new prime number this
is we suspect we are or we're definitely
the first people to have ever printed it
out I suspect we're still the only
people to have ever printed it out
because that is over 2 million digits
printed in tiny tiny type I went for a
mono spaced typeface to make it easier
to locate the digits within there
oh there's a mistake ah that's not right
so I mean people get very excited when a
new prime numbers fell but very rarely
do you actually get to pick it up and
hold it to this it's some serious
there's some weighty there is some
weighty mathema look at that look at the
size of that number and this obviously
I'm environmentally friendly I want to
waste paper so it's it's front and back
now finding prime numbers is a common
hobby for mathematicians and you know
from millennia thousands and thousands
of years math editions were obsessed
with finding prime numbers
with no factors and now it's getting
harder and harder to break the world
record of the biggest prime number ever
found and so the previous world record
was three years ago and if anyone has
been watching number five videos for
that long you remember we covered it
Tony did a video on the previous world
record and that record stood for three
years and now we have another one but
they're getting so much harder to find
and so this one is almost five million
digits longer than the previous one and
so it's gone from around 17 million up
to around 22 million you think I thought
it's a decent jump we don't forget every
digit the number is ten times the size
and so that's another five million
orders of magnitude bigger I mean that's
just off the scale so the record has now
been taken by Professor Curtis Cooper
he's at the University of Central
Missouri and he was running loads of
computers there he found this prime he
won the world record off the previous
holder which was Professor Curtis Cooper
of the University of Central Missouri so
he's won is his fourth prize he's
hogging them to be entire I mean I I run
the software to I really want to find a
world record I'd be happy with anything
in the top 100 biggest known primes but
notes he's hogging the top spot and so
he found two in a pair about a decade
ago and then someone else got the world
record back and then he regained the
world record three years ago and now
he's just cemented his position he is he
is captain prime so the way this works
if you want to try and find the biggest
prime known to humankind is you just you
don't have to do anything really you
download a bit of software and you run
it on your computer so as we speak
there's a computer in my office running
a bit of software to try and find prime
numbers and some central server will
send your computer a candidate number
your computer will then check it to see
if it's prime or not and more often than
not for the vast majority not prime so
you send it back and go sorry guys not
prime very occasionally you'll be sent a
number your computer will check it you
won't even know you'll be out and about
and a number like this takes about a
month so your computer will sit there
for a month on a number like this at the
very end it's not going to be prime
but very rarely if it comes in prime it
gets sent back and officially you found
it it's your record the policy is a
number only counts as a world record
prime once it's been seen by a human
because obviously this numbers always
existed this number predates our
universe so it's not like we've invented
it we've just spotted it and so your
computer finding it is not enough when
it gets flagged up that it exists and
the human goes hey check it out
that's when it officially counts as a
new prime number and so yeah so you can
win you whether there's a prize but
that's beside the point
you can win you know accolades and
recognition as the finder I'm so envious
sounds like a lottery winning here and
yet this one guys won at four times
what's you see it does sound like a
lottery doesn't that they're just
handing out numbers curtis's secret is
he has a lot of computers so he's
running on 800 desktop computers so he
had a chat with the people at the
University of Central Missouri he said
look all your computers you've got them
running in the labs around the night
like they're on 24 hours because
apparently it's easier to push updates
and things to the computers and so they
deliberately keep the one egos we don't
a waste all that computing power and so
they agreed to let him put the great
internet Mersenne prime search or gimps
for shorthand terrible if you're going
to look it up online don't google type
out all of great internet Mersenne prime
search and he put it on all the
computers and so for the eight hundred
computers at the university there
whenever they're not being used they
kick in and start doing this or some
computer sat there for a month during
the date was helping people learn people
were coming in using it for assignments
and university work and at night when
everyone turned the lights out
it would fire back up again it would
reopen this not go right where am i up
to right and then it would carry on and
it would check if it was prime or not
and for one of them it's suddenly ding
at the end result it was prime and I got
sent off to the server absolutely in
girl
the twelfth term in the Lucas Lima
sequence but we only have to find it mod
8 1 9 1 so to start with it's the same
you'd have 4 you'd square that you get
14 you'll square that